the [ __ ] will love this that's the
intro right there it's gonna be the
[ __ ] will love this marks down
shoo-shoo
now recently the government got in touch
with us
I think his email address is what day
that government was it and he said you
need to make tennis more interesting and
then we came up with this yeah we did
basically this is petrol in here yeah
that's a tennis ball so soaking it with
petrol and I'm gonna serve it now
obviously with it being caked in petrol
yeah how you gonna stop all the petrol
from landing on your face and arm yeah
that was the step one yeah he gets
annoyed when people tell him he's got
missing Callister in the canister I know
it looks like an angry team fortress to
momen stand there and admire the shot
while my hand is on fire
you
it's what I'm filming stuff like this
though I just think what on earth do we
do for a living
welcome to the dumbest thing that I've
ever done
well I think that was oh you're firing
it
jizz B I think that went pretty working
in the government we very pleased with
what he accomplished I've got a sore ass
thankfully it wasn't on fire by the time
the ball reached me my hand is warm
you got a warm hand well then it's a
great video
and we came up with this yeah we did